since World War two the US military has
been sending teams of soldiers onto the
battlefield with film and photography
gear to document the action these so
called combat camera teams often provide
the only depictions of major military
operations and the work helps shape
public perceptions they've been called
propagandists guilty of sanitizing the
realities of war on the ground in 2003
for example when soldier Jessica Lynch
was taken prisoner by Iraqi forces it
was a combat camera team that captured
her rescue by US Special Operations the
Pentagon was later accused of
dramatizing details of the rescue to
lift waning public support for the war
in 2008 an eighteen-year-old recent high
school graduate named miles Lugosi
signed up for the Marines and became a
combat camera videographer for his unit
in Afghanistan after his deployment in
2011 Lugosi went rogue shooting footage
that undermined official messaging
including scenes of marine smoking hash
and joking about death after being
discharged from the Marines Lugosi
compiled that footage into combat
obscura a new feature-length documentary
that aims to show the real story of
what's happening on the ground in
Afghanistan the Waris was so mismanaged
there were so many different moving
parts and so many different bureaucratic
levels that we weren't really watching
18 year old combat camera kid and where
he was going what he was filming the
film offers a horrifying but honest look
at the desensitizing effects of war and
the failure of American exceptionalism
abroad
[Music]
what did you do in the Marines you get a
camera and then you go around like what
were the parameters you were allowed to
do a lot of shots with the Afghan army
because at that point in 2011 when I
deployed we were supposed to be
transitioning out I see yeah that didn't
go well so a lot of the shots that they
wanted were of you know the Afghan army
working with the Afghan army giving kids
candy and stuff like that there weren't
too big on like actual combat
anaesthetic is kind of the wrong word
but like what was your story sense then
are your spider sense like that you
decided this is the kind of stuff that
I'm gonna go to again and again I was
sort of trying to capture what I'd seen
in war films like Full Metal Jacket and
stuff when I started working on the film
years after I'd gotten out I really try
to deconstruct that whole what I was
doing out there and put it into
something very different there's a lot
of scenes in the movie where where the
guys that you're dealing with yeah I
mean it almost looks like a YouTube
video where they're playing to the
camera
how do images of war end up affecting
how people act in war and then you know
is that a is that a virtuous looper is
that cut himself defeated one what I was
was kind of like an outlet for them and
even like my nickname was youtube when I
when I was out there because they wanted
to be the way that they wanted to be
seen amongst themselves not so much like
how a civilian would film them as far as
like the broader issue of like what
effect does imagery have I think it's
tough because a lot of this footage is
already out there on these kind of war
porn sites you know if you want to see
pretty much anything you can just google
it and find it as far as like putting it
into a feature documentary I don't think
it's been done too much in the past I
think that a lot of the documentaries
and especially news coverage that comes
out tends to sanitize it I think with a
civilian reporter or civilian journalist
there's still kind of a barrier there
that you're not gonna break through
you're never gonna be able to film them
you know being completely honest or
joking about death there the way that
you see in the film and stuff like that
that's a part of military culture they
can really only come from within it I
think
[Applause]
no day me the other day you show at one
point marine smoking hash it's kind of
surprising that I mean it's not
surprising that it's you know what's
happening but it's kind of surprising
it's in the movie what what was the
choice behind including that or what was
the thinking behind that what was a huge
part of our deployment you know it was
it was a way to kind of pass the time
but also to remind ourselves that we
were in a war zone because he gets so
boring after a while that you're like
you kind of you get into stuck into the
routine of patrol night watch post you
know back and forth back and forth that
you you forget to look around and see
that these are people's homes and these
this is a beautiful exotic place that
you're in you know and the people are
constantly giving it to you we would
smoke weed with weed smoke hash with the
locals it was kind of that way to like
break down the barrier you know it's
sort of like a universal language of
just laughter and stuff like that when
you're out there you don't you're not
really thinking about the bigger picture
what are we out here for when you know
what is it like to be out here you're
just kind of living day to day and and
constantly patrolling and just kind of
worrying about your next meal basically
and the guys that you're with trying to
keep them alive
is that a callback to earlier movies and
I'm taking of evens or novels like All
Quiet on the Western Front where the
platoon it I mean it sits on the ground
so like you don't really have that
larger sense of what a mission is we
want to reflect like the emotional
uncertainty of war in the editing of the
film the lack of narrative and
everything we want to kind of recreate
that that uncertainty and the experience
in real time but I think after sitting
through it you know maybe digesting it
well you get a kind of broader picture
of you know how this war was just there
was no there was no chance that it was
gonna work like from the beginning in
the long run and is that because there
was no or at least as far as the ground
soldiers understand it was no larger
objective or clear goal that was being
served I think so yeah and I mean even
if that goal could be achieved like if
we were to get rid of the Taliban
completely what comes after that you're
talking about regions
we're the people you know they don't
even identify as Afghans they don't have
a national identity they relate they
identifies whatever tribe they belong to
so I mean yeah no thought really went
into the end goal what was gonna happen
after when you were there was it
successful in getting rid of the Taliban
or was it just they were rope-a-doping
they were just waiting like I mean you
see what's happening now they would
shoot at us from you know hundreds of
meters away and then as soon as a
helicopter or air support came in they'd
be gone and you never saw them
I mean you rarely saw who was shooting
now that we've handed it over to the
Afghan army and we're not actively
working with them or patrolling with
them they're just getting absolutely you
know massacred because they don't have
their air support they don't have our
weapons they don't have the technology
there are the training and the Taliban
is literally over running their bases
you know like getting hand-to-hand
getting that close you got hurt in the
middle of this and the camera turns on
you what is it like to get wounded and
deal with I mean it sucks yeah first but
like the whole time I was out there
leading up to that point when I was hit
I think I had this air of invincibility
and the camera kind of added to that you
know I just wanted to film as much
combat as I could and everything I was
obsessed with filming everything and
after that I was kind of like you know
it really gave you perspective that
these people are you know trying to kill
you personally and it became very it
felt very detached before and then it
became just incredibly personal in that
moment there what were the extent of
your injuries I just I mean it was I got
a piece of shrapnel it luckily it went
through my helmet strap so it didn't dig
that deep in it's very superficial
obviously this is the only war that
you've been in but it's a volunteer
force is that better or worse for morale
do you think I've thought about that a
lot you know I mean on the one hand
you're getting a lot of kids that want
to serve their country and they maybe
actually do believe in what they're
doing but then you get a lot of kids who
didn't get it in college you know
they're getting basically bribed to go
serve their country to get money for for
school which is insane that you actually
have to go get
in another country in order to afford
college is ridiculous
then there's other kids like me who kind
of wanted to experience war just because
it was something that we had reified in
our minds as something that you know you
become a man by going to war you you
learned something by going if there was
mandatory service it might actually you
might actually see less wars because it
would bring the wars home to pretty much
every citizen I mean if we're if we're a
country that's gonna be perpetually at
war then I think everyday citizens
should be acknowledging that and that's
maybe one way to to do it the war in
Afghanistan has been going on for I
guess that's coming up on 18 years right
it'll be in the in the fall assuming
it's still going on did you get a sense
when you were there that their people
had different feelings about it in the
kind of in the first three or five years
in the second etc or has it just kind of
blurred into a you know just kind of a
fact of nature keeping American people
yeah yeah I think it's just kind of
background noise at this point you know
people still thank you for your service
but it's often kind of frustrating
because it's I'm not sure what they're
thinking us for do people actually feel
that us being in Afghanistan and somehow
made us safer here I don't know if
people actually think that I don't think
that and I don't think in the long run
it really served the Afghan people that
well either but you know it's a very
complicated thing how do you there's
Afghans that didn't want us there that
want us to stay there the Afghan army is
like where did they where did you go
we've lets us out you know to just get
slaughtered you talked about
deconstructing combat as a reality
what's the big hope that you have in
making this movie and bringing it to an
audience I think we're at a point as I
mean as a veterans especially where we
want accountability not just for the
military industrial complex but for us
the kids that we're out there to you
know if we can give people a sense of
that through this kind of this difficult
film which is very difficult and I think
we've we've done our job and if it makes
a kid who's thinking about joining the
Marines you know they give up some
hesitation then I think that's good too
do you feel like America you know is
becoming more realistic about what it
can accomplish through war I hope so
I'm a little concerned because it's all
Special Forces now and we're in these
you have special these small units that
are that are all over the world in
almost every country now and there's no
coverage whatsoever I mean there's not
even combat camera that's with them
there's no civilian embeds there's
nothing because it's all classified
everything they're doing is just being
conducted in the shadows and that's not
to say that what they're doing is bad
a lot of times we're just training local
militias and stuff but we should know
what they're doing we should know who
they're training we should know why
they're training them should know where
they are and why don't we I mean it's a
fight but that's why is a classified
because there's Special Forces so JSOC
the Joint Special Operations come in
everything that they do is classified
but right now they happen to be doing
everything if you happen to be fighting
in almost every country and so it's very
disconcerting that there's absolutely no
coverage of these guys and what they're
doing
I think Afghanistan's gonna be the last
actual on-the-ground troop war you know
like regular troops out there in mass
bulk what is your opinion of the war now
that you've made the film and you've
been able to I mean cuz you shot all of
this in 2010-2011 put it together it's
out how has this process changed your
attitude towards the war in Afghanistan
I mean going into making it and having
the dist having some time to look back
at all the memories and then the footage
that I had I definitely started becoming
more critical of of our involvement and
what the old man goal was why we were
there in the first place and just
reading about the history of the country
in the region you know I had no I
couldn't even point out Afghanistan on a
map before I went out there you know
that's not a good thing so just
educating myself and then going through
the footage and being more candid and
honest with what I've included it
started to make me more critical but
more empathetic at the same time in a
way I'm trying to humanize the troops by
showing their fault
you know what I mean and that's how you
kind of think that's the best way to
take human eyes
[Music]